[Musique]
oui
là
[Musique]
les avions
jamais
je crois pas
et au caire font plus de free voici bain
de minuit spécial brasil à l'éléphant
blanc avec ce rallye sydney penny robert
mitterrand fait tasca qui jacques weber
mais juste avant daniel toscan du
plantier et yves navarre j'aime beaucoup
de bouquins mettait pas un graphomane
on va pas vérifier combien de tableau
d'un peintre ou fort heureusement on
était on l'a pas dit à monsieur frantz
schubert qui décrivait trop de musique
est mort à ces jeunes d'al aridha cbl je
veux dire c'est un bon point que l'on ne
fait qu romance ou dans ce temps-là sud
consommation passe t elle on dit qu'il
publie trop mai
écrire trop ça n'existe pas on écrit on
n'écrit pas évidemment écrire ne se
décide pas une décision je ne prends pas
j'ai besoin d'écrire ça veut dire debout
je ne me pose pas de questions je ne
vais pas m'arrêter d'écrire simplement
pour crever
il ya une chose que je vais te demander
quand même quand tu es parti vous l'avez
connu à l'époque ah oui ah oui moi si
oui quel ventilateur de couloir ouais
bon ben on peut demander mieux que ça
annonce est extrême et c'était très chic
les couleurs publicis est bien simple je
ne croyais pas qu'un jour
j'ai rencontré daniel heidi rien
pourquoi les bien ça parce que sinon ils
vont bien sûr je te laisser parler
quelques minutes ça dure déjà
non mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait il y
avait un climat y avait aussi rené
victor vit on ne va pas parler de l'usb
il était là magnifique et je crois que
tous les deux un peu comme quand il
ouvre la bouche le jeu casters parce que
lui est venue à paris la marque tout
naîtra alors oui alors moi lorsque je
voulais dire c'est que daniel tu as
connu à l'époque tu avais quand même une
nature enjouée vente avait des moments
comme ça de soins le soir de temps en
temps mais enfin tu avais quand même une
nature plutôt bien et plutôt déconner
c'est tout et qu est-ce qui qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ajouté le courage de
tout quitter tu as écrit des bouquins
qui d'une façon générale ont été plutôt
bien accueillies
je pense à nous comme je pense à des
choses comme ça qui tout de suite dès le
début il ya eu qui leur est due tout ça
et pourquoi tu
c'est toujours une ère comme ça à peu
écorché vif un peu
c'est rigoler je crois que je suis
relativement drôle dans la vie j'aurai
est relativement sérieux d'environnement
peut-être parce que dans la cité ga coup
devant soi
la mention honorable
et qu'après dans l'écriture
j'ai voulu des pratiques et les
rassemblements se
voir à l'écran peut pas dire que tu
montes dans tes livres quand ton stylo
et vit depuis mon stylo et voilà et puis
non enfin ce sera même un petit peu plus
loin je ne quand je dis que la piste et
la publicité d'une école du mensonge
c'est très subtil ici avec beaucoup de
considération
et que j'ai appris d'une part à peser
les mots à savoir quelles étaient leurs
retranchements doublement champ à savoir
qui pouvait être leur leur envol la cité
d'aba et en même temps à me méfier mais
ça prend un visage en fait ça apprend en
effet repoussé révision c'est vrai
j'aime ces bouquins oui je vais juste
choses là sur le guen 15h papa
fait partie de tous les producteurs il
fait partie de ceux qui vont toujours
dit à mon peut il ya un producteur
italien qui est assez grand copain qui
m'a dit un jour gérard longuet se tue
dans les femmes je le fais à mimer des
tours ne fallait pas le faire synopsis
se tendent à venir à bout et moi je
n'aurais pas vu que tu ne connais pas
les lire
j'ai un peu près le même rapport
le plein
je me place pas s'il vous plaît attendez
qu une fois je dis la vérité si vous
entendez la vérité comme une flotte
c'est votre problème
mais il va le genre aussi de se poser un
peu comme
victime mais moi j'ai beau conspiration
pour ceux qui écrit parce que c'est très
dur dans une sorte de solitude de vienne
se contredire parce qu'il se pose en
victime et on se voit parle de la
solitude
éthique c'est dur et oui c'est dur c'est
la solitude c'est en se postant vivement
les victimes pour ceux qui choisissent
le tir et profite de ce qu'ils créent
oui je ne sais pas la peine voilà que
j'adorerais si les profits de ce qui
crée sa randonnée que je vais garder
pour les 20 prochaines années au final
sur la largement trait aux finances à
l'usma mal tiré profit aussi de ceux qui
produit secret mais moi je suis content
parce que je crois que
aujourd'hui il faut mieux être du côté
de la création que du côté de ceux qui
produit tu racontes dans ton bouquin que
c'est très dur une fois tu vas amsterdam
comme ça pour faire une conférence et
que c'est très dur ça demande des
efforts de venir la télévision pour
parler de ce que tu fais terrible
terrible série
une sorte de terrassement parce qu'on
devient
alors j'ai le souci du pater
je vis avec un chat way je fait plonger
comme un embryon
gérer je surnage encore noyé dans la
grille aimé presse
et
l'exercice social de l'écrivain société
médiatique en faisant les grands mots
est une chose qui me dépasse d'autres
temps
j'en connais tous les rouages
alors jeune homme comment être sincères
et le paraître
je pense qu'on peut pas être sincères et
le paraître à la télévision pour
paraître sincère à la télévision il faut
être pas sourde
aux cimaises à vos sujets
mais je vais faire ensuite s'emballer
à tous de s'y jeter les limiter
les bras mais président att s'est tu
m'as dit tout à l'heure je survis
pourquoi elle cherchait depuis
alors je verrais tu prendras une
question qui va me donner
m'a demandé pourquoi je dis moi est très
bon
au début des années 70 oui parce que le
début des années 70 c'était la fin des
années 60 ouais
j'en prends vaches
et je pense effectivement
effectivement je constate
que nous avons perdus par exemple le
sens des saisons nous sommes connus à
l'époque rêver des saisons
on vibrait et on vivait au rythme des
saisons et demie il fait très beau cet
hiver là c'est pas normal
même saito sympa non bon moi j'aime bien
les saisons soit marqué tranchée est
maintenu à la fin des années de deux
faux billets au début des années crise
et je crois que l'attend ce soir les
années de construction absolue alors je
regarde
parfois je m'abuse de voix sans moi de
moins en moins avec réseau mais qu'est
ce qu'un véhicule
vous étiez revue tous les deux puis les
poches des revues y passait fera quand
je vois le faire encore
viviane hamy il vient d'avoir la palme
d'or à cannes on va lui aussi l'a eue
ces petits les concours gilleron les
mâles tous les deux sets acharnés
face il ya deux là font qu'il est sûr de
lui et moi je doute du tout je ne sais
pas je mets en couple a droit nous
devons l'homme je ferai tout ce qui est
fascinant chez lui c'est sur la planche
sa certitude
vous avez tous les deux des moustaches
c'est pas consultés
je crois qu'il va tourner court
quel avenir je suis un battant
on travaille pas seul brillante elle
alors d'avoir on reste dans le flash
back avec john sebastian et les lovin
spoonful ridgway
[Musique]
non
m
ma femme
[Musique]
pas
non
[Applaudissements]
pour paris
et max oui mais
si souvent
m
[Musique]
mais pas
thomas
le second tour
m
moi
les
café noir pour une nuit blanche ce soir
le pen se la maison de café spécial
brésil
or bintou bonjour salut clown ce rallye
qui c'est qui va ce deuxième éléphants
blancs carnaval brésil
locker nova lfs l'automne
et 56 ans très nouveau brûlé le ban avec
le music show
tu verras et cinquième chanson haïr à
marcia maria il y aura céline hobart aus
1 école de samba avec ton 16 et plein de
percussionnistes alice gueule
et on chantait quoi ils vont chantier
tout si c'est ça on commence avec le
prieur
parce que c'est toujours comme ça après
on attaque un new orleans année houleuse
en arrive de trinidad près tout de suite
on se trouve à rio à ses magies c'est
laquelle oiseaux c'est vrai que
s'achevait loison il sera dans une
savane
bonsoir madame et messieurs
est ce que vous êtes 'prudent'
est ce que votre coeur recommencez faire
ton temps en temps
cette entente c'est partout
car il ya moment chacun des locataires
deviennent floues enflammé que l'on perd
le plus coloré que paradis
de ces instruments
m
ce week-end à martin riman ilan in and
out ou trois pics droite comme à gauche
à la mi temps
il se prend l'avantagé
je crois que là
comme on l'entend comme le bas
canon
non
donc adieu
à
mais sûrement
c'était compliqué
après dieu
madonna
non
oui
non non non
ah ah
adam key illustre à new york
pendant que m
que non
je
m
entre
oui
mitterrand va-t-il se représenter
va-t-il passer la barre des 60% on en
parle avec son frère
j'avais une manu sabban soir paul
benmoussa bonsoir thierry robert
mitterrand bonsoir bonsoir je suis très
heureux de vous avoir parce que voir le
frère du président de la république au
bassin événement quand même enfin
surtout par la première fois comme avant
vous êtes déjà venu au bar oui je suis
jamais marc était enfant vous avez ça
n'étonne pas vraiment voulu ressembler
c'est incroyable oui il a été fait
sûrement modèle un passionnant
servi de modèle à l'heure on a apporté
quelques perfectionnements des petites
valeurs des fois je vous regarde plus
ont un peu la tête comme ça attention
c'est à côté du nom monsieur le frère
aîné oui oui j'ai autorités c'est
dommage et puis la monarchie parce que
ça serait bien oui oui ah ça vous devez
recevoir et vous seriez roi de france
était quand même formidable regardez
vous verrez le président dans le public
dans trois ans oui c'est vrai
ils sont solides dans cette famille un
bon je n'ai pas dites moi donc vous avez
fait un bouquin qui s'appelle frère de
quelqu'un chez robert laffont le titre
est très très bien bravo c'est vous
c'est de moi mais je vous félicite
pourquoi vous avez fait ce livre pour
être célèbre pour gagner de l'argent ou
pour faire plaisir la célébrité très
problématique ouais oui non c'est pas
pour ça je les fais
parce que j'ai lu petit à petit les
livres qu'on écrivait sur mon frère et
au moins 50 m plus ou moins bon mais en
tous les cas assez inexacts malgré les
efforts qui sont louables vous en
pensez-quoi lin soudé tient à ton compte
en tant qu en aidant à faire un petit on
va passer en revue les livres de
catherine née sur votre frère vous en
pensez quoi je pense que là c'est un
très gros effort de votre vie très gros
travail qu'elle a dû la du talent
surtout pour les porterez elle a très
bons coups de griffes où
elle
là abonde on s'entasse d'exactitude par
rapport à ce que fait normalement granby
giesbert as je crois que en fait je
craque c'est le meilleur au point de vue
exactitude il a seulement son côté
naturel de d'aller un peu vers une
vérité puis de recul et un tout petit
peu il hésite un petit peu mais il est
le plus près de la vérité c'est
impensable de gira jean-daniel ses
covenants sont libres on n'a pas parlé
plus encore oui mais voilà oui non jeu
comparé au précédent non
jean-daniel je n'ai pas lu son livre
mais je pense qu'il est très sérieux
malgré tout dans ses recherches
de tous n'est ce pas non pas ce qu'ils
racontent quelque chose que moi
puisqu'il cherche analyse un caractère
ceux qui cherchent à le faire une
psychanalyse il ya quelque chose de très
théorique enfin gratuit c'est
intéressant ce sont des jeux d'avant
élection je vous avoue que sans arrêt
c'est maintenant l'heure n'ont ils pas
ce qu'on m'a dit fais gaffe chez les
mitterrand il y en a un qui parle pas
est un qui parle tout le temps oui c'est
vrai oh non non rien n'a pas un qui
parle tout le temps 12h55 ah bon donc
qu'est celui qui est président c'est
suivi par la mémoire le moins qu'on
appelle quand ils ont qui paraît à bonne
escient ah oui j'en attends je n'aurai
pas la prudence de vous demandez pas ce
que tous les journalistes vous ce moment
mais on a dit qu'il parlerait au mahatma
voilà bien des gens ne parlent jamais
oui c'est bien toi je l'attendais depuis
que je suis n'a pas encore grave
alors dites moi votre frère et il l'a
relu le bouquin eh bien il est en train
de le lire mais il a lu avant que ce
soit imprimé un non non non non non je
lui ai montré un passage de notre
enfance il a dit c'est exactement ça oui
parce que tout ce qu'on raconte sur
l'enfance en général c'est enjolivé
c'est un peu d'effort mais aussi raconté
par des membres de la famille qui en
trois ans qu'à 20 50 plus qui donc on
vit avec des yeux différents mais comme
nous ne l'avons une faible différence
tous les deux auront vécu sereinement
tout près l'un de l'autre alors c'est
exactement ça et c'est mon souci
d'exactitude ce mail en vous apportant
appelée onu technicien sait je peux pas
m'écarter de la vérité il vous est pas
le rappeler pour vous dire qu'ils
étaient pas contents ah non non au
contraire il est content alors comme il
ne voulait ne distribue pas les
compliments en abondance il m'a dit
petit à petit d'abord c'est tout à fait
ça et puis après il m'a dit c'est bien
ton livre
réédition va marquer une bande rouge
avec ses bientôt et
c'est pas mal écrit enfin c'est 1000
couples maison qui naissent ajoutés les
uns aux autres tout va bien il me gonfle
et d'eze bah oui c'est dur à faire un
livre en plus c'est très dur alors
parlons 18,3 des petits scoops dans le
livre quand même alors qu'est ce que par
exemple sur l'action française sur
l'observatoire sur des choses comme ça à
l'action française une année très peu
question car elle n'en avons jamais fait
partie simplement nous avons appris
qu'elle était interdite par le vatican
oui si nous en faisions partie le jour
où le vatican l'intérim ne saurions
c'est pas vrai c'est à mon tour je suis
rempli des voix la wii à l'observatoire
vous donnez une à l'observatoire jeunes
n'hésitent pas à vous raconter pas
d'histoire dire exactement tout ce que
je veux qu à ce niveau là comment ça
m'est arrivé oui façon extraordinaire
n'y avait quasiment mon père en face de
moi un vieux directeur général de
semaine faire way qui me dit robert il
ya des choses qu'on ne fait pas dans la
vie
j'étais tout d'un coup on trouve les
gars plein travaux nomine oui je viens
d'avoir paris au téléphone nous étions à
madrid et à madrid j'arrive à paris en
ce fameux attentat voilà bien c'est
votre fer qu'il a organisé son complice
viens de le dire avec du gras dans la
main moi j'étais à s'emplir jouer
disparaître j'ai eu honte où je me suis
dit non c'est pas possible françois n'a
pas pu faire un truc comme ça pour mille
raisons et pour des raisons morales et
même pour des raisons pratiques clients
qui vous dit qu'il avait rencontré
pesqué depuis deux mois que c'est pas le
genre de type votre frère a monté un
coup à quelqu'un qui connaît depuis deux
mois devait pas plus le moins depuis
huit jours depuis huit jours par an il
avait rencontré la veille
entretien ouais et l'autre la découvrir
après huit jours avant dans deux
entretiens avec lui s'est paré de 24
heures l'attentât a eu lieu le soir mais
ouais on monte pas et dans des lieux
pendant que vous avez raison c'est une
explication qui ont pu si on veut faire
sa mort à jouer non mais si on voulait
faire un coup à coups fumants quand on a
été le chef de la résistance avec des
milliers de personnes soit 16 ans et
qu'on a décidé entre les fidèles
pourraient découler plus dur par
l'assistance on va prendre une sega là
on va pas prendre un team qui est un
repris de justice qui était un
un député poujadiste et évidemment tous
prêts à vous faire un croc en jambe tout
à fait dites moi avec votre frère vous
voyez souvent ah oui une ou deux fois
par semaine a quand même ah bah oui vous
fait quoi quand vous voyez est bien
souvent nous prenons le petit déjeuner
ensemble nous parlons des événements du
moment nous parlons aussi le souvenir
nous prévoyons un petit déplacement
ensemble une promenade chez les
libraires ou de dominos une demi-journée
en province comme il y va de temps en
temps ils invitent quelquefois alors
province avec lui poehl tu dans son
restaurant que moi j'appelle chez paul
d'ailleurs tout le monde quand il
s'appelle chez gartner
moi je suis tout le temps en fait c'est
paul tu vois des parents vers différents
ben oui le bureau alors avec mon autre
frère voilà avec le général avec le
général ah oui mais voilà oui c'est vrai
mais tu es partie de celui ci avec rené
ma deuxième et la suède aucun n'a les
lettres aux frères oui
c'est toujours pendant trente ans après
monsieur le ministre est naturellement à
cause de la ressemblance et puis après
on va vous appeler monsieur le général
est un joueur vous attendre à un autre
nul les deux jours à vous a demandé de
faire réformer quelqu'un ou d'autres de
transférer qu'elle vous avez dit non je
suis à mirage a amené une demande avec
marc et monsieur l'avenir dites-moi
quand il était petit bout les 17
présidents votre frère non non on n'a
jamais pas le soir elle a pris en quelle
année abbas a surpris le président
syrien petit à petit en commandant quand
on est homme politique on commence par
vouloir être député oui il a été maintes
fois il avait été assez jeune il avait
29 ans bah oui et puis il a été ministre
à 30 ans comment ça se traduit la
tontonmania il ya des mid et
mitterrandolâtre ouais il y en a quand
même oui oui bien sûr bien sûr que c'est
chez moi c'est le le temple de la
cohabitation ben oui bien sûr car du
président de l'agglo abidjan
les choristes ont reçu absolument tout
le monde commence à raconter des ennemis
qui arrivent on c'est très rare ces
trois ans passe toujours très bien passé
y a qu'à voir la cantine de l'assemblée
et c'est que des lieux comme ça qu'ils
sont ouais le bon vin karine au menu
lors des matchs et ça c'est une suisse
quelque part ça se passe toujours très
bien se dire que même où autant les plus
difficiles du début de 80 n'a jamais eu
chez moi personne qui a subi deux sens
aux
manifestations aussi personnel jamais
ils subir à vous en avez subi non mes
voisins il voulait plus vous parler en
bien de 25 ans s'est habitué
des coups de téléphone
injurieux
robert mitterrand vous êtes quand même
le frère de quelqu'un le père de
quelqu'un vous êtes le parrain gx et les
siens jeudi savez il ya un chapitre
entier qui sera gérée j'ai élevé cinq
enfants y en a il y en a d'autres aussi
qui sont remarquables c'est pourquoi je
dis maillage jean-gabriel j le frère de
jeu sud vers de frédéric mais je suis
fier de lui mais je suis fier aussi de
jean gabriel d'olivier de catherine de
maxime et ceux ci font des choses qu'on
ne voit pas la télévision ils sont des
feux des projecteurs j'allais vous
l'aimez frédéric mitterrand comme
présentateur pourquoi il vous plait
pas qu'il dise on est 100 il est
possible il agace certains il en celui
d'autres oui
il n'est pas différent
non hélas à la base une grande culture
etc oui on est vous raconter l'histoire
des olympiques et tous et très
courageuse qui l'a fait frédéric enfin
vous lancer là dedans bois quand il a
tenu le coup pendant 12 ans oui 12 non
c'est très courageux moi je lui avais
dit
quand il fait de la pub vous en pensez
quoi ça c'est déjà un peu plus et ben je
suis mais une phrase là dessus dans les
cinémas d'art et d'essai qui ont été
très prisés il a perdu de l'argent il a
des dettes où et quand on lui demande
pourquoi il va fort envoyé son talent
dans la pub il discute et je tiens
rembourser mes dettes et danser
l'enfance quand on m'offre 250 mille
trois cent mille francs pour tourner un
petit bout de trucs de trois minutes
même pas ouais ouais
ben je le fais là oui c'est permet quand
même de
de m'acquitter de m'acquitter de mon
dieu c'est bien moi je trouve ça bien
souvent mal aime bien et puis là de la
fantaisie
temps en temps
alors que dans l cette semaine et il
attend il torse nu s'est bien posé la
question ce matin c'est à dire pourvu
que le reste ne soit pas venu chez saab
at il était déguisé en yvette horner
le brésil vers vous en parler du prêt à
le brésil c'est mon second pays se
sentent pas traîné je connais le brésil
depuis 40 ans j'y vais tous les ans et
quelquefois trois fois par an j'ai
trouvé le moyen d'y travailler j'ai fait
le plan de développement des mines de
fer et ces parias je faisais 8 millions
de tonnes vous savez combien le font
maintenant parents font maintenant 60
millions de tonnes c'est lui qui devrait
être président
en hommage à michel fugain de la part de
thierry et ali pour partie comme
l'oiseau voce abou sow marcia maria
jeunes enfants
la
professeure
[Musique]
à
théo
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
c
oh
ils ont battu
au sort
gfr du ciel des belges est perdu
guidé la guerre j'ai perdu deux passes
j'ai comme envie non
aujourd'hui pour elle il n'aurait gêné
s'est pas gêné c'est plus gêné ces
majestueux
et
c
aïe
annoncée
c'est là
et à
awesome
c
rousseau ok
à
seul
ces
sommes
on sait
à bord
m
la route de nairobi se terminer rue du
bourg-l'abbé dans le bureau des patrons
des bains c'est greta scacchi là tu as
tu es arrivé qu'on a parlé
ce matin je rêvais doux de l'andrh quand
tu viens pour la sortie du film la route
de nairobi oui c'est ça j'ai déjà
intervenu à faire ce temps benbada avait
comme ça dans toutes les télévisions
pour vendre pour film mais d'habitude à
cause d'un film sort je suis en train de
tourner l'entreprise alors j'ai jamais
l'opportunité de l'essieu dispensé de la
promotion d'habitudes ouais mais cette
fois
je travaille pas pour les prochaines
semaines alors je fais suivre le film
dont tout prix en europe et en amérique
mérite ce soir
le 11 mars
non
maxence
avec ça
je mens
[Musique]
oliver nouvelle vocation
il ya cinq ans maintenant que j'ai lu le
livre le producteur celui qui a acheté
les droits d'une
m'a fait mal mal fait lire il ya cinq
ans et il fallait beaucoup de temps pour
avoir l'argent un finances par le film
et c'était après la sortie de succès
dans du barca finalement les financer
sans sont mis d'accord c'est michael
radford kg quant à fait plein de signes
qui sont super tu refais chaleur est
haussière tu as fait coca cola kid un tu
as fait le film de jane kurys aussi
qu'elle est très bien en amoureux avec
qui tu as préféré travailler de tous les
metteurs en scène depuis tous ces films
que tu fais depuis quelques années
je ne sais pas
moi je suis très exigeante comme matrice
je suis très critiqué et
je rappelle que l'expérience de chaleur
poussière qui c'était ma première film
c'était terrifiant pour moi c'était très
difficile et je me suis senti très
abandonné de james avery que ne dit
jamais rien presque rien ces facteurs
mais maintenant réfléchir maintenant que
c'est passé cinq ans et
j'ai maintenant je peux voir le film
et comprendre pourquoi ça a eu un succès
a eu beaucoup de succès bien sûr ce que
je trouve que quand j'ai fini de faire
un film et je le vois le résultat je
suis toujours déçu je peux pas oublier
mais mes images mes rêves du film et
maintenant je vois chaleur sur les
russes hier et
je peux la miray et j'adore james avril
est toujours instable
ah parce que le club a confiance
adressée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moubarak
e
et qu'est ce que tu fais quand tu fais
pas de film c'est quoi ce que notre faim
dans ce bureau ont parlé avec harrison
ford disait quand il faisait pas de
faits et couper du bois dans son jeu
qu'est ce que tu fais toi comme moi j'ai
pas un range
j'ai un petit maison à londres
j'adore londres je suis jamais parce que
je suis toujours en voyage pour un film
et mais quand je suis là je trouve c'est
comme paris il ya beaucoup de cinéma
beaucoup de théâtre je fais des cours de
danse j'adore ça
c'est plein de choses à faire t'as pas
de rendre encore j'ai une interview de
toi dans vsd ou tu disais que tu étais
avec une journaliste dans le hall de
l'hôtel et bien des très beaux garçons
qui sont arrivés dans le hall et tu as
tu les a regardés ouais ça il ya deux
semaines s'est cependant je crois que il
y avait là lamanda paris comme
l'indiquait un
prêt-à-porter ouais j'ai beaucoup de
même que c'était des mannequins qui
qui cherchait de travail oui tu
t'intéresses aux garçons
je sais pas pourquoi elle a elle a écrit
sa douleur que c'était elle aussi que
regarder les messes étaient des cadres
non vraiment et j'ai j'ai noté qu'il y
avait un très beau garçon et puis il ya
une autre et puis à la fin il y avait
une cinquantaine de des trieux beauvois
je suis enfin ma fiancée
oui c'est vrai culte est parti à cuba
c'est ça
c'est partir d'amérique du sud qui
savaient pas où je sais tout sur toi
oui finalement j'ai fait un vacances
c'était superbe année album booba rio en
bolivie a été rude et août est allé en
argentine non et à cuba tu as trouvé ça
bien dont j'ai lu dans le journal que tu
as trouvé ça bien que oui c'était très
très intéressant parce que c'est un
gouvernement tellement différent de les
nôtres c'était très intéressant surtout
visitait un set d'un film d'un très très
bons metteurs en scène comme un qui
s'appelle thomas scouts hier un salaire
très bon et a parlé avec les acteurs
qu'ils encourent à
tout le monde et employés tout le monde
il n'y a pas de
m shon chômage chômage chômage
et les acteurs il gagne le même tout le
monde s'il travaille ou pas ce travail
dans le ter dans les cinémas sabia toi
oui c'est intéressant parce que
en comparaison elle et les acteurs en
angleterre au moins le l'ambition la
compétition c'est un des
choses
plus dominants au plus fort du vide de
l'acteur de survivre dans un monde dans
une monde
très difficile à réussir
donc tu serais pas socialiste
je suis intéressé à ça et j'ai remarqué
après visiter cuba compte comme nous
avons visité brésil et bolivia surtout
apparu que là bas il y a tellement de
misère plus de misère au pérou en
bolivie qu'à cuba à oui biensur coup bah
c'est pas riche mais tout le monde a un
toit tout le monde a à manger et ils ont
dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour les
écoles ont l'éducation et à la fin c'est
quoi les priorités de la vigne est ce
que les gens sont pas plus libre en
bolivie au pérou quand même non mais ça
dépend de ce que tu tues tu crois que
c'est la liberté à en cours ben oui
c'est difficile en train c'est difficile
de partir
mais je crois dans l'histoire du sud
amérique que la koubaa montrait que
peut-être la socialisme c'est la seule
pensez à ces socialistes quand même
assez rare de voir des jeunes actrices
comme ça qu'ils défendront je dis pas
que le gouvernement de cuba a
pourrait fonctionner en angleterre ou en
france mais là bas où il y avait un an
avant il y avait le
capitalisme et les gens qui
meurent est du fin de l'épidémie
c'est
à moins de
2 de finir tout ça
[Musique]
cuba pour cuba voici le dernier carnaval
avant la chute de baptiste
[Musique]
m
merci
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
eh oui
et
m
[Applaudissements]
et a fait monter l'école de samba
apparaît bien il existait déjà des
groupes et des écoles de samba
beaucoup d'éléments d'ailleurs l'école
viennent
de différents groupes qui se sont formés
et qui ont été appris la batucada parce
qu'ils avaient avant tout le brésil et
les rythmes brésiliens auxquels est
lancé il ya des brésiliens il ya des
français on peut dire à peu près 70 %
est composé du français de nombreuses il
y un an ce rallye pour cet éléphant
blanc spécial brésil t'inviter rémy
kolpa kopoul qui est le plus grand
spécialiste français de musique
brésilienne ce nom juan oui c'est normal
tu vas vite et longtemps là-bas moi je
vais je viens ouais y'a rien il ya un
ascenseur salvador qui s'appelle les
débats dans la serre dans les jeux
j'avais entre la ville basse et la vie
des autres donc la vie aux autres c'est
paris la ville basse ses notes sur son
de tous les temps bien ça dépend de
trois fois quatre fois par an comme ça
toujours quelque chose à faire là y'a un
choix j'en ai maniban gobrait de vue
parce que je pense que c'est bien tout
d'amener la musique africaine les gars
savent aussi qu'ils connaissent pas la
wallonie qu'après une antillaise moderne
des coups mais c'était génial toi tu vas
me parler dans notre style de musique
vous voyez je vais vous parler parce que
effectivement quand on pense au brésil
on pense avant tout avant tout aux
écoles de samba est en ce moment à rio
c'est désormais chose
c'est des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui défilent
devant des centaines de milliers mais à
salvador plus au nord c'est autre chose
qui se passait encore un récif encore
davantage mais salvador c'est une ville
très africaine pour ça que vraiment on
dit afro brésiliens et pense avant toi
salvador c'est d'ailleurs cette année
soit l anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé au brésil et c'est ce qui
est fait est aussi bien les épaules de
son pari au coeur à salvador fille
on m'a posé des goupes affronte ce qui
se passe à salvador c'est que chacun
navale où on participe d'ailleurs chacun
à vannes où on assiste à moins que l'on
ne participèrent parce qu'ils croient
que c'est que effectivement c'est un
million ou deux millions de personnes
dans la rue mais qui inventent des
choses cette ville a les facultés
d'inventer les rythmes d'inventer des
danses d'inventer les styles
extraordinaire et je me suis mieux avec
une à avoir un avis
qui s'appelle fafard parfois d'amaya et
qui va vous montrer la dernière
invention de salvador s'appelle la danse
la galerie l annonce de l'afflux des
poules de la foule a dit vous allez voir
que le mouvement du postérieur évoque
irrésistiblement
alors on peut imaginer des milliers de
postes de long pesant ça ça donne une
basse cour alors on va faire comme la
télévision
avec en conséquence si ce groupe
s'appelle al hodoud est un groupe qui a
vendu de son hymne album à salvador
avant moi et c'est l'événement de cette
année du canada christian présentement
salvador
python
il préconise à anthony concourir à tous
les âges et
tous les
opprimés y compris
africa news now tokyo pour y en a trouvé
ça on est bloqués vers la gare 19 /
nominative des hommes 1
netanyahu s'est aussitôt mais j'y ai
mes os x dans
les rails
tout aussi jarry du film on fait
supporter ça y est
mais
nous
le brésil c'est pas classe en masse et
aussi les nazis voici le meunier de
rudolf hess hester charte gabelle vous
publié chez plon un bouquin qui
s'appelle conversation interdite avec
rudolf hess puisque vous avez été
lemonnier de rudolf hess dans la prison
de spandau pendant neuf ans première
question pourquoi 9 ans pourquoi pas
plus que si vous est arrivé il a eu un
problème effectivement j'avais en
quelque sorte promis à ce vieux
prisonnier à sa famille et également à
l'église allemande que je resterai le
plus longtemps possible à berlin et que
j'essaierai de l'accompagner jusqu'au
bout alors ça n'a pas été possible parce
que les soviétiques sont intervenus un
certain moment dans cette affaire et ont
après quelques mois obtenu que je quitte
vers là il ya plein de mystère s est
quand même comme le masque de fer ou
quelque chose comme ça il son
parachutage en angleterre oui mais bon
il se fait parachuter en angleterre et
finalement on découvre que la gentry
anglaise était plutôt pro national
socialiste avant guerre il y avait plein
de il y avait plein de membres de la
gentry qui était pro national socialiste
avait même une certain qu'ils
prévoyaient une une union entre
l'angleterre et l'allemagne pour dominer
le monde et remettre à ce moment-là
edouard 8 sur le trône est ce que vous
avez eu des des éclaircissements à ce
sujet ce que vous vous avez
d'éclaircissements sur la raison pour
laquelle elle s'est fait parachute en
angleterre en 41 non je dois dire que je
n'ai pas de révélations à faire et que
le livre ne contient pas disons de ces
de ce genre de révélation parce que
c'était un personnage assez renfermé de
nature depuis toujours et qui avait
tourné la page sur ce passé alors ce
n'est que de temps en temps par hasard
des rues au hasard des circonstances
qu'on a évoqué son vol vers l'angleterre
son séjour là bas mais je pense que s'il
ne m'a rien dit il n'a jamais rien dit
non plus à personne il n'a pas écrit de
mémoires il ya effectivement des choses
qu'on ne sera peut-être jamais en 2017
puis ce que cherchent ils à a demandé
que les archives soient ouvertes
seulement soit bloquée jusqu'en 2017 est
ce que vous êtes sûr que c'était le vrai
rudolf hess parce qu'on a dit aussi
qu'une fois qu'ils aient été parachuté
en angleterre enfin qu'il a sauté en
angleterre on l'a remplacé ya même un
type qui a dit moi j'ai fait j'ai fait
un costume de rudolf hess en cinq heures
et à ce moment là ça sera un fonds qui
serait qui aurait été ramené à nuremberg
pour être jugé mais je vous parlais du
livre d'un médecin britannique les
sanitaires britanniques qui est en poste
à berlin à une baisse entre les mains si
j'ose dire la radiographie etc et a
constaté qu'il avait pas que lui il n'y
avait pas la blessure suffisamment de
cicatrice à la blessure au poumon la
guerre de 14 ans après ça a été vérifié
par plusieurs chinois est l'un des
alliés on a constaté qu'il irait bien
des traces donc c'était le vrai de vrai
pour sa famille pour les amis pour moi
on a dit aussi que dans les années 50
staline avait fait extraire s de la
prison de spandau pendant un jour ou
deux pour lui proposer de diriger un
petit parti est allemand je restais le
parti national démocrate de façon à
récupérer un peu les anciens nazis qui
vivait en allemagne de l'est est ce que
vous avez des lumières à ce sujet est-ce
que c'est plausible d'abord ce n'est pas
très plausible parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait les autres condamnés avec lui il
était encore tout cela je pense et puis
il y avait des gardiens alliés
occidentaux qui étaient là jour et nuit
les langes et qui est gardien soviétique
on peut pas le seul
impensable qu'on est sorti de nuit
complète sans que ça et transpirer
sellerie fallu acheter les gens je ne
peux pas m'opposer à ce que l'historien
allemande et à parler a dit mais je n'ai
parlé avec s j'ai connu cette histoire
il ya plusieurs années vous avez parlé
avec ses preuves avec lui lui a dit que
c'était tout à fait impensable qu'il ne
se souvenait de rien qui ne voyait pas
comment la chose du tt possible alors le
grand dernier mystère au sujet de rudolf
hess c'est sa mort c'est à dire qu'on a
commencé par annoncer qu'il était mort
sa belle-mère et ensuite qui s'était
suicidé et son fils que vous connaissez
bien wolf rüdiger
a dit que c'était pas possible qu'on
l'avait un peu se suicider quand même
qu'on l'avait un peu aidé à mourir
je pense que ce serait sans doute aller
un peu loin je connais les lieux dont on
a parlé ce qui me gêne un peu c'est
qu'on n'a pas permis à la famille et à
l'avocat de s de voir les lieux et
d'avoir l'explication j'allais dire
matériel de suicide on a fait
disparaître ces lieux très rapidement et
puis les alliés ne l'avait annoncé que
le lendemain de la mort ensuite le
surlendemain on sait qu'il y avait un
petit papier dans sa poche ça faisait
pas très sérieux et ça fait un peu
penser qu'on l'a un peu aidée quoi
qu'ils aient un peu de thé la's il a
derrière l'enjeu je ne veux pas y croire
je vais simplement s'il lui s'est
suicidé telles que je les ai connus il
ya eu des tentatives de suicide bien
avant une fois en angleterre et une fois
je pense d'eau avant mon arrivée mais
après pendant ces neuf ans et demi et
jamais été question de suicide se
maintenait vraiment vie voulait vivre il
voulait encore voir ses petits enfants
ils voulaient encore essayé de sortir
puisqu'il faisait des demandes de
libération alors il a fallu pour qu'ils
se suicident qu'il est soit une
dépression sénile brutale ou que joyan
tout ce qu'on lui faisait tout ce qu'on
a ajouté à sa peine au cours de la
dernière année parce que j'étais de plus
en plus dur fait tv tension que c'est
cette incroyable de plus en plus dur
parce que may en chasse et moi et ne
pouvant rien de faire il a fallu qu'on
se venge sur quelqu'un alors on sait en
somme comment il s'est amusé ion s'est
vengé sur le vieux monsieur de 93 ans et
sur mon successeur lemonnier qui ya
beaucoup moins de liberté que tiennent
beaucoup ma liberté que moi qui ne
pouvait plus aller au jardin avec lui
qu'il pouvait parler que de religion etc
le fils de est ce qui a donc mis en
cause la thèse du suicide a été victime
très rapidement d'une congestion
cérébrale est ce que là aussi c'est pas
un peu bizarre ça fait très remontée
john le carré quand même dans tout ça
c'est donc c'est tout à fait exact lundi
me plie j c'est pas quelque chose qui a
pu être provoqué la partielle
non je pense qu'il était sous le stress
il avait des problèmes de santé à ce
moment là et puis le stress de la
semaine ça lui est arrivé de voyages à
prix doux et son père était mort le
lundi soir donc le stress de toute la
semaine et peut donc ça ça peut pas être
vraiment mis en cause quoi non non ça je
ne pense pas mandanda grill rsa
l'hôpital très longtemps je pense qu'il
était encore en cure non donc vous vous
deviez assister enfin vous deviez
prononcé une allocution pour
l'enterrement qui finalement n'a pas été
fait dans le petit village où c'était
prévu on l'enterrait quelque part sans
doute a sans doute à munich et vous n'y
êtes pas allé le président l enterrement
et je puis vous dire qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'enterrement et que le dernier mystère
de sa vie c'est que seule sa famille et
peut-être quelques autorités savent où
se trouve le corps moi je n'en sais rien
alors beaucoup de gens ont milité pour
la libération de rudolf hess vous aussi
d'ailleurs et dans votre livre on sent
que peu à peu finalement au cours de ces
années vous finissez par avoir je dirais
presque une certaine tendresse pour lui
est ce que c'est pas un peu un peu
bizarre ça quand même
non pas du tout vous savez il n'est pas
pensable qu'un prêtre un rabbin ou un
pasteur aille vers des gens qui
souffrent tous prisonniers souffrent
quels que soient québécois qui les fait
danser se nomme souffrent on peut pas
aller vers lui la bible en main et lui
lire l'évangile sans l'aimer à partir
même du premier jour tout au fond de moi
même je sais que si je vais dans une
prison je dois aimer les gens qui s'y
trouvent même rudolph hess donc sa part
déjà delà de ces notions chrétienne de
l'amour à tout prix je les
inconditionnels et puis après au bout de
neuf ans vous savez un vieillard qui vit
et qui devient de plus en plus un
vieillard qui marquait par l'âge et dont
l'espoir de sortie diminue on s'y
attache même des gardiens il y avait
autour de moi quand même la dgac on a
sympathisé indiqué nurenberg il n'avait
pas été condamné pour crime contre
l'humanité puisqu'il était en
quarantaine pendant que la solution
finale était appliquée en allemagne mais
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui dans la
prison de landsberg avait écrit mein
kampf avec hitler qui est quand même
fait partie de la tue le 2 et le shaft
et qu'il y avait qui avait participé à
toutes les labos ration de la théorie
nazis donc est ce que finalement même un
prêt tu peux aimer quelqu'un qui a qui a
inventé tout ça même si ensuite il ne
l'a pas mis en application savez les
idéologies des fastes court le monde et
cela a été extrêmement néfaste mais nous
ne pouvons pas prouver à l'évangile en
main nous refuser accordé d'amour à un
être humain parce que pour nous du rêve
tous les hommes et que pensez vous de
l'attitude de serge klarsfeld qui
étaient contre la libération de s alors
excusez moi je préfère ne pas ne pas
répondre à cette question je préfère
simplement dire qu'il y avait à paris
qui lie à paris un avocat juif
un vieux monsieur
qui est un juriste distinguer qui écrit
beaucoup de livres sur le droit
international et qui en 1984 publie un
article dans le monde avec un grand
titre grâce pour rudolf hess et ensuite
dans mon livre je parle d'un entretien
bilatéral qui n'était pas pour mais qui
n'est pas content c'est à dire il me dit
moi je n'ai rien dire si vous arrivez à
le faire libérer je me tairai je préfère
répondre comme ça merci s'appelle
comment
vrai nom c'est comment
[Musique]
tu pensais qu'elle a jugé paul
salanne
[Musique]
monsieur riches n'ont
pas vécu avec lui
n'étaient pas mariés
25 avait 12 ans
c'est quoi
je fais des vitrines et
[Musique]
les coups quand même temps au total avec
cinq ans cet arrêt mais à l'époque où tu
vivais avec lui c'était comme un garçon
non non non a15 était déjà très si je
suis déjà fallait il était vital est
excellent parce que maintenant c'est la
mode n'est pas levée à mon époque on
disait être avertis c'est quoi la
différence entre un vestiaire qu'on
s'est fait maintenant on dit qui est un
travesti ce garçon que c'est des crises
en femme village en les embrassant
c'est quelqu'un qui nous
conduit tout enfant
leurs dix mois après comment tu la
quittes et ce type s'était
il a tué non
il défie noyer
s'il n'était pas mort pour et contre
l'avis de ranrupt l'annoncé le premier
amour tu as pu passer toute ta vie avec
mon riz rebonds et voir comment t'es
venue en france
on n'a pas le vent compagne pourquoi de
rapports définir
beaucoup d'auto paris et toutes les
plaintes excellerait vignes à paris
arrive dès qu'on dit transsexuels on
pense à brésilien c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est pas parce qu'on a toutes les
capitales c'est pas pareil à paris est
là plus qu'ailleurs il a plus qu'à
londres où il y en a plus qu'un oui et
l'as rome
et disons rien à compte
bah ouais je pense que tu
soutiens d'accueil la france
m'a passionné des techniques à dépenser
devenu à quel âge ici
[Musique]
c'est comment tu vis en france qu'est ce
que tu fais des spectacles des galas
une mutation comme neige
comme en province le cotec du
consommateur
oui j'ai même une famille et
intérimaires oui j'ai rencontré un
garçon oui il ya longtemps que le but
lui maintenant ça fait bientôt sept ans
a battu à chaque fois c'est vachement
long
[Musique]
très habile à tous les hommes qui sort
avec moi elle est en visite avec moi
parce que je
leur dis moi je fasse un peu personnel
comme question mais toi tu es quand même
toujours n'a pas été
excellent contre 17 1
500 femmes
opérées ou
non
beaucoup de gens
yanina pas pourquoi des de travail parce
que
allende je veux te baiser décliné l'aide
dans le passé la psychiatre mais j'ai
tout donné
dans dix jours
ah oui à la grèce a coûté
4 mondiale à katyn mais que sait-on
fillon ce qu'il a offert un petit peu je
regrette pas les choix dit quoi peut pas
être fait c'est un garçon non
parce que c'est très bien comme ça si tu
penses que c'est parce que tu fais comme
ça quand tu es né ou c'est parce que
tous les besoins d'argent à un moment
non non parce que je suis moi je voulais
vraiment d'argent j'étais des cours tous
les jours gras sexuelle brésilien qui
vient en france et vont tout seul
oui moi je ne gêne pas j'adore le
diffamer vision à tout le monde
j'adore fait la star les à travers
femmes c'est ça ou des tarifs
bas minuit spécial brasil l éléphant
blanc avec ce rallye carnaval annulé
[Musique]
il
m
on va parler de smallville ben oui on va
remonter un peu un peu plus dans le nord
du brésil de vraiment ce qu'on appelle
le lord est à dire du côté de ce récit
fait de toute la région la plus pauvre
du brésil mais en même temps une région
historique sur la musique du carnaval et
là bas c'est très différent c'est les
cuivres qui défilent sur des camions et
les gens qui dansent derrière ces des
rythmes beaucoup plus speed beaucoup
plus rapide s'appelle le frevo
alors il ya c'est ce qui est descendu
après à bahia qui a pris
larguer les cris qui a pris les guitares
électriques à la place qui fait qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir du rock saturé à
salvador mais
agressif c'est resté beaucoup plus
rustique dans le land s est resté
beaucoup plus rustique et l'accordéon
c'est dans l'instrument de prédilection
de là-bas alors oswald qui est un grand
musicien c'est un des deux ou trois plus
grands accordéonistes du brésil il est à
paris en ce moment pour peu de temps ils
se présentent au disco fages et donc on
a profité de sa présence pour montrer un
peu ce qu'il sait faire alors il va nous
jouer un frais vos le même qui a
complètement enflammé montreuil à
quelques années est bon c'est un artiste
de top niveau non merci alors on va le
dire va est au cas où france la fevad
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peu
[Musique]
ma
coc
[Musique]
ah ah
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
dis donc tu ressembles pas beaucoup la
bernadette du film
ça c'est mon côté sydney
côté là
16 17 en août
why you are here we c'est pour ça que
tes parents sont là
il faut que jamais la paix
mais c'est loin et californie desquels
ils sont venus avec toi pendant le
tournage
s'il faisait pas confiance à de la loi
confie t il
elysée confiance monde une famille très
unie tout et
que leur seul enfant
non ses deux frères et deux soeurs mais
alors les soeurs elles sont toutes
seules en californie non pas du tout
elles sont mariées mais
maintenant je vais tout seul
quand on sera ensemble
s'ils pourraient venir santé par envoi
d'accord mais ça c'est un délit
c'est vrai que du sang indien
oui un sixième de centre cherokee
et quoi d'autres
français
mon arrière arrière grand père c'est
daguerre
l'inventeur du daguerréotype d'accord
dès lors j'ai du sang écossais j'ai du
sang et hongrois c'est un peu la
hongroise
[Musique]
à
alors
[Musique]
oui
it's very stains de choses oubliées
c'est quand même marrant gaieté prix toi
pour faire ce rhône
pyrénéenne du
jeu ressemble quand même
ovidiu startin' cinéma tu as commencé
comment au cinoche
d'abord je bosse avec mes parents sur
scène
c'est le numéro de music hall
mon père est comédien ma mère aussi
mon père joue de la guitare
et puis un jour comme ça pendant une
pause café ils ont décidé que j'allais
monter sur scène
j'ai commencé à raconter des histoires
et puis on ne peut plus manger de la
glace n
et puis depuis j'ai essayé de faire des
progrès
j'ai commencé à six mois
j'ai fait c'est pas toi tu filmes
smtd et puis j'ai fait perdre rider
avec une telle chose ouais m audi de
jean delannoy choose your et de loin été
choisi comme ans
il avait vu les oiseaux se cachent pour
mourir
mais ce n'est pas que j'avais 10 ans
il s'est dit j'avais 10 ans il se dit
maintenant le dois en avoir quinze je
vais l'appeler
a new world chose
mais quand tu été choisi pour faire
bernadette avait vu le film breaking
la chanson de l'année
oui quand j'ai fait le film j'ai cherché
tout ce que je pouvais trouver sur
barney
et j'ai vu le vrai histoire et ça a rien
à voir avec le film danois king
dis-moi sydney était croyante toi ouais
c'est à aider pour être berman est bien
sûr
son épouse
non en fait oui tu vois un acteur a pas
besoin de savoir exactement ce qu'il
joue il à avoir son point de vue
d'acteur ou d'actrice
mais moi je croyais vraiment emballé
mais c'est une vingtaine de move édition
tous que dans le film est vrai
alors ça veut dire que quand on a vu le
film le dg de frouard ouf
bien sûr c'est une preuve
six mois ils ont essayé de montrer
qu'elle était folle ou qu'elle voulait
tromper son monde mais ils sont pareils
et c'est dur de pas
encore où et quand on voit son corps à
la fin qui est conservée parfaitement
cent cinquante ans après c'est cette
foisonnante
et l'air de dormir
bonne idée de son corps n'a pas du tout
changé
nick fry et a fait comment pour parler
français alors
c'est pas facile
alors tu articulé en français qui a
prêté des doublés quoi c'est ça
enfin j'ai travaillé tous les jours
toutes les semaines avec madame d'écart
qui mon coach
bien sûr plus ça avait plus été facile
je parlais que les gens me son plateau
sur le tournage
et après je comprenais le script en
france
mais dis-moi jean delannoy il est pas
comme ça un peu copieux pour faire les
films que tu penses que c'est la crise
non c'est pas un crime mais enfin je
sais pas est ce que quand on a 80 ans on
peut faire un film pendant des années 80
jean delannoy peut faire des films
partout et toujours
c'est un génie
in france' vous verrez que tu sais qu'en
france il a quand même été pas mal
critiquée par la nouvelle vague jean
delannoy
maintenant je savais pas plus faux
truffaut godard chabrol tu vois
je ne connais pas
je reste un peu chez nous alors je
reviens bab el oued ou came to french to
be bad
what did you want mais quand est venu en
france pour être bernadette il a dit
quoi ton fiancé la danse et avec
tout le monde m'a beaucoup aidé quand je
les lui ouais ouais ouais mais voici
tout ça n'était pas de blessé tout seul
en californie
[Musique]
est ce soit l'ama fait long feu
c'est le genre de truc lesquels il faut
mais qu'ils s'habituent
il accepte bien oui cela mieux
[Musique]
après bernadette soubirous un miracle
n'arrive jamais seule voici l'album
sylvain bergère
[Musique]
rudolf fesses
jean claude gallotta
jean cau
monsieur lesage le preneur
villalonga grand d'espagne
ferreri iconoclaste
moravia méprisant
franck maubert
guy tu es basse
dans m le maudit de fritz world
les ailes du désir vim bergère
soirée de gala à l'opéra orphée aux
enfers
la princesse napoléon jacques chazot
marina de brantes emmanuel d'euros
l'unmis nature in à alexandre ni qui
n'en sais ça c'est les mêmes mais c'est
sur scène
[Musique]
[Rires]
renata zan
dîner au foyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et french cancan pendant le dîner
serge lama son père chanter à l'opéra
françoise laclau ce eric bergeault
[Musique]
oh
après sylvain chez les riches sylvain
chez les pauvres
bercy austerlitz 12e 13e
à 12 ans de l'an 2000 le 19e est
toujours là
on
[Musique]
mon jour
seul pack au pool tu connais ce rallye
sur sourire je suis absolument garder
ses maîtres de l'éléphant blanc ans
qu'elle fait ça va prendre quelque sorte
le sambo le défend blanc
alors dis nous c'est qu'ils varient
surtout ici à paris dans le monde entier
qui c'est céline au barreau sedin au bar
aussi le plus grand musicien nord du
brésil à paris des sports absolument et
il a un vrai génie parce que je tous
sortaient en ce moment porter leurs
pulsions
ou un nom plus haut on
peut parler
à personne
puisque les yankees des gens qui vont
comprendre pour ce genre tout le monde
sa mais dix minutes à traduire il faut
se dire laquelle il va le jouer de la
guitare universel alors c'est quoi la
vie universitaire quand tu vois ça
serait énorme gateway dicko reja
premiers corps fin de phase aller ce
dernier fait le guitar à ces médias les
images en même temps c'est au chômage ça
et pourquoi personne n'y avait pensé
avant lui je sais pas demandez lui
comment s'occupper céline ans pourquoi
personne n'a pensé à savent pourquoi
personne n'a pensé à ça avant toi ou
guitare universal
on cherche toujours la complication il
ne pense jamais aux choses très simples
veille à rémy qui dit que ça va mettre
la moitié des orchestres chômage
instructeur non non parce que il ya une
question de personnalité c'est à dire
qu'en fait quand on prend le musicien il
ne faut jamais prendre pour l'instrument
qui joue mais pour ceux pour le musicien
lui-même on peut même avoir des
orchestres avec deux bassistes pourquoi
pas diamètre l'important c'est la
minorité a aucun
nom mais là c'est simplement
c'est juste que pour moi justement ça
qu'il veut
[Applaudissements]
mais
olano grâce aux flèches du monde à
condamner
et
montage est importante et j'étais cuit
pas déconner
manèges la vie m'a dit qu'à d'autres
avaient joué
et
bah
ayez évacue nourrir et pas qu'une
oreille
et baby blues
[Musique]
du coup
et
chacune
évacuée et pas une ride
bello et jacques weber jouer tout le
temps au bas mot non je n'ai pas le soir
ici sans entendre des comme ça a
vraiment joué dans un juge vient de
temps en temps quand je cachais les
périodes de fainéantise quoi de rêverie
je trouve pour alterner les gros moment
de boulot avant jette à corps perdu il
est moment de on se répète pour garder
les gens c'est à dire combien le monde
tannerie parfois très ou trop longtemps
j'sais pas moi c'est relativement court
mais j'aime bien ce à quoi vous bien ou
alors avoir joué puisque après avoir
joué un peu en ce
moment c'est plutôt une période placé la
période monacale à effacer un faux faut
dormir parce que convoyage pratice 15
ordres épée par jour frais hier la
sexyness que je joue je mets en scène
j'ai écrit deux textes vous allez faire
monte cristo voilà ouais alors c'est
marrant parce que ben sassi jamais fait
ou au théâtre il ya eu 49 l'adaptation
cinéma et bizarrement jamais au théâtre
une seule fois par ailleurs
parce que j'aime bien avec vous c'est
que quand on pense à des acteurs de
théâtre on pense à des types comme ça un
peu intello un peu recroquevillés un peu
ça c'est la réponse à sa vraie comprends
pas pourquoi mais on n'est ce pas parce
que vous avez dû suivre c'est un peu
nouveau ça quand même ce retour aux
grandes mises en scène aux acteurs qui
moi je préfère un ou comme ça qui
déclame un peu qui je crois que c'est la
grande grande tendance actuelle c'est un
moment très bien d'ailleurs formidable
où le metteur en scène a vraiment pris
sa place on a découvert d'autres
dimensions comme celle toute simple des
acteurs dans des rideaux noirs mais
maintenant les gens ont tellement marre
ils sont tellement abreuver de taff long
d'image peinard installé confortablement
dans l'automate et qu'ils ont besoin de
l'accident du thé altéad sachez au
présent donc le théâtre c'est la liberté
de ces grands monstres dont il faut pas
que les acteurs soient des porte
manteaux et l italie des deux metteurs
en scène sont faut que ça soit avant les
types libre qui rentrent doute dans la
sur la scène comme le torero fasse un
ton qui ne connaît pas et beaucoup
d'image on parlait de la cornada
moi je suis pas fou totale de la côte
est un exemple alors nouveau film c'est
un peu moins bien commun moi c'est
carrément nous avait glosé de ce qui
s'est passé non mais c'est vrai que ce
côté là comment ça se fait ça je crois
que je serai pas maman il ya une grosse
moi jte pas parce que tout simplement
c'est pas les films forcément que des
mauvais temps là certains dans ceux des
faits qui sont pas apportées mais parce
que j'étais pas bien j'étais pas prêts
chacun les acteurs qui sont très très
vite comme il est truffaut à être nue
paraît qu direct gérard depardieu il est
comme obélix il rêvait dans la marmite
même à gagner n'est pas moi ce n'est pas
mon pas moi je me sens beaucoup plus
libres bizarrement ce sont au large sur
la scène le 100 libre la caméra je me
sens un petit peu et 3 passes pour ça
que j'ai décidé maintenant de revenir au
cinéma par le biais de la participation
de petits rôles wen devrait apprendre
jouer avec des grands trop souvent fait
les acteurs de dollars avant d'être soi
serait à prendre pour qu'un jour si ça
pouvait venir sur ce vraiment un beau
rôle quelle importance que j'ai aucune
envie de tenir cinq fois dans l'année un
pistolet pour faire une énième flic le
énième gangster ça m'emmerde les pros
d'être hambourg all un peu la manière
donc reviennent au cinéma des tom conti
beenkens clair c'est très prétentieux ce
que regardent les angles en angleterre
ça se passe oui ce sont des grands
acteurs de théâtre alors peu c'est
différent le marché est tellement
important qu'on peut se permettre de
prendre un inconnu
un très grand rôle et puis la
superproduction est là pour attirer
alors c'est un peu plus difficile mais
c'est ça qui souhaite moi et sinon plus
que je vais aller attendre du cinéma
qu'en chine quelque chose vous êtes une
star du théâtre vous le regrettez pas
être une star du cinéma va pas du tout
pas du tout sam a chatouillé quand
j'étais jeune c'est vrai il ya ainsi
plus qui a dit un truc est vraiment
sympa c'est faut jamais oublier que la
gloire c'est toujours un accident dans
une carrière et je trouve ça formidable
la carrière elle est très longue et les
plaines d'artisanat et je crois que la
longueur d'une carrière c'est sur les
terres pour la troupe et puis bon bah
s'il ya ce petit cadeau merveilleux
d'être un petit peu vedette au cinéma
pourquoi pas mais pas à n'importe quel
prix quoi à nice vous avez à voir avec
jacques médecin bull c'est votre patron
est le cas par bah c'est formidable
parce que médecin est un gars qui a mis
les choses au clair dès le début mais
c'est à dire il a dit il se peut il
avait raison d'ailleurs qu'on ne soit
pas du même agent on n'est pas la même
image politique mais entre temps à
écouter vous fais du théâtre ça vous
savez ce que c'est moi j'y connais rien
moi je m'occupe de mon truc quoi couper
vedette macha et c'est tout plaire et à
partir de ce soir est un homme qui
jusqu'à maintenant et qu'ils trouvent
sans arrêt a totalement respecté ces
engagements par rapport à moi ils voient
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe sur
le plan théâtral à nice et il nous aide
mais vraiment à fond vous êtes le
couvent saint servais bien aidés par la
municipalité
ça va coûter combien d'aller voir monte
cristo d'aller vers jacques weber dans
le rôle des deux mondes en test
des places est ce que c'est pas parce
que c'est c'est ça le seul grave
problème c'est que je crois que c'est ça
c'est que le prix des places est
beaucoup trop cher pour le client c'est
vrai c'est affreux
351 bon nous je crois tu es meilleurs
sont à 250 points c'est vrai que c'est
excessivement cher et d'un autre côté
tout le monde s'est tu
sais j'ai reconstruit 2 et 6 vraiment
sale la chose qui risque de crise a
ajouté m vous êtes bien appeler bien
m'en veut complet vous avez l'air bien
un formidable
38 ces jeunes des world s'approche la
fameuse pente on est en haut et à
auxerre
à
[Applaudissements]
quoi
à
[Musique]
coût
oh
bah
[Musique]
oh
bakou
[Musique]
non
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux